hello everyone and welcome to an
extremely wild game that was played
yesterday in chess calm städel Tuesday
between Indian grandmaster Chetan Barham
Aravind and Ali Riza Fallujah and it's
one of those games that's just
completely crazy so I I do believe you
will enjoy it without further ado let's
check it out and if you haven't do check
out a who guys new song like I mentioned
in the previous video the lyrics are
written by none other than uh ninja diri
the link to it will be the first thing
you see in the description below so do
check it out if you if you enjoy hookahs
content or if you haven't heard any of
her songs yet now getting back to the
game Aravind opens the wit Knight to f3
he goes for the red team sorry about
that
that was a super loud 192 of six and now
III so the so called quiet system of the
ready we have g6 preparing the Finca to
the dark square Bishop ended b4 now we
have Bishop to g7 and Bishop to e2 so
both players are now ready to castle
which they do so castles castles and d6
now preparing a 97 and maybe to strike
in the center with E 5 which is what you
usually want to do when playing against
the ready
so c4 and Knight B to d7 further
preparing e5 we have Knight to c3
aravind continues developing and now II
five by Allah Reza and here it's this is
all very very standard theory there's so
many games played in this line most
common move here is Queen to see you but
b4 is also very popular which is what
Ottoman goes for he wants to create a
pawn storm here on the Queen side where
it's a lira sock he wants to close up
the Queen side and play on the King side
much like you would do for example in
Kings Indian defense so rook to e8 and
now a 4 he continues his plan on
expanding on the Queen side we have E
for challenging that night and now
Knight the d2 we have Knight the f8 now
here I'll address this plan as he wants
to play h5 he wants to shift this Knight
over to h7 then bring it to g5 then
later on use it for attacking purposes
we have b5 are I mean continues playing
on the Queen side and ali reza plays on
the king
so both players ignoring each other you
know I don't care what you do here and
these guys says I don't care what you do
on the other side of the board and here
a five is unknown move in the position
however are I mean here goes for rook to
e1 and this is now a new move in the
position so Alireza continues with his
plan like a to h7 and Bishop to a3 now
developing developing the piece we have
Bishop to f5 Alireza does the same and
only now a5 we have a six biologies a
and now not capturing but rather
advancing to b6 and now it the pawn can
be captured for example if you capture
white will most likely play some like
Ruby one or Queen to b3 to go after the
b7 point if you further capture and even
though if you capture let's say you grab
a queen capture some b7 black can win
upon however it's a double a pawn and
you kind of don't want to do this what
you want to do is what I addressed it
you want to close up the Queen side and
transfer the game on the Kings side as
he or most of your forces are here look
at them all you know you're just hanging
out here so Queen to b3 are developing
the Queen connecting rooks and now push
her back to f8 we have rook eat the c1
now as the rooks are now connected
Ottoman brings the rook over to the C
file and Knight to g4 now and it's a
very close position on the Queen side so
it's very hard to to clearly see what
kind of breakthrough white can hope for
on the Queen side however Ali Reza knows
what he wants to do on the King side he
wants to attack which he does with
Knight to g4 and now you could capture
here but then for example after captures
captures then the Queen comes to age for
the night comes to g5 and it could be a
very promising attack for black so h3
forcing the knight back and here ali
reza moves the knight back or or does he
if the night went back i i don't think
we would be showing this game here
instead of knight f6 Alireza goes for
Queen to h4 and now he offers a full
piece here which are wind of course
accepts it's the best move in the
position so H captures and g4 h captures
and now Knight to f1 preparing to bring
the knight to g3 to add another defender
so tonight the g5 by alavesa he brings
another attacker here closer to the
white king and now night the g3 i just
replacing than I dare to be used for
defensive purposes and now well you
could continue this game in many ways a
dress that just goes you know like we
mentioned in the previous video goes all
in so nice the f3 with check and this is
complete madness now now the point is
after the after we captured the night
which is definitely the way to go for
example G captures G characters in the
ship f1 not allowing let's say Queen h3
to get checkmate the white king what is
doing what is doing well he has both of
his knights and the black has no Knight
so white is up two pieces of course if
you survive the attack you should be
much better however after this night to
have three check Ottoman believes all
arrested that this is a strong move and
he plays King to f1 instead and King to
f1 well it kind of completely blunders
the game so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the best move for
ali reza while i give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
supporting that night - did you check
pics of the queen and well that's all so
for those of you just wanna enjoy the
show
however ali Reza missed this he didn't
go for night study to check he instead
played Queen to h2 he prepared Queen to
g1 checkmate and here white is forced to
capture the night so G captures on f3 we
have eight captors on f3 and now King t1
if you go back to d1 then a lot of a lot
of cool thing things happen for example
there should be one then comes Queen G
to check King g1 you're gonna go Queen
g1 check king d2 and after we finally
capture the bishop prevents the King
from escaping to any light squares you
will have to start the giving back
pieces and white black will just happily
capture and so on so after this he
captures on f3 move we have kinky one by
ottoman and also III really I really
enjoyed this game especially but we're
gonna we're gonna talk about that after
I show you the entire game
so King to e1 and now Queen to g1 check
by Alireza
Knights the f1 King still keeping an eye
on this pawn here and now well you could
go for g3 point being that if pawn
captures the rook can just gobble up the
e3 pawn Alireza just goes goes again all
out with rook captures on e3 and this is
just wow so the rook has to be captured
you don't really have an option here so
f capture is only 3 and now g3 and now
the past bones are marching forward we
have King Tubby to giving up some
material you cannot prevent the
blackphone capturing absolutely anything
but here we have g2 or it as a
continuous pushing so he is in no
reverse gear mode this game we have
Knights to g3 not allowing the knight to
be captured and now Queen to h2 as this
also opened up an attack towards the
Queen so Queen h2 and now Knight
captures on f5 so you don't have you
don't have time to play f2 you could
play it but then Bishop characters on d6
comes with an attack on the Queen and
the white successfully trades off even
more pieces so first G characters on f5
and now rook the g1 blocking the past
pawn but now f2 by allah reza and now
white has to give up something so rook
captures on d2 check you have so much
material you don't really care about one
rook so Queen captures on g2 and now
Queen to d1 blocking of course the DF 1
square preparing the Queen th one Queen
to f1 at least anything to get rid of
blacks Queen so rook to e8 ali reza
brings another rook into the attack and
now Queen to h1 offering a queen trade
which of course all it is I cannot
accept he's down material so Queen to g3
and now Queen to f3 kicking away the
queen preparing group to f1 to get rid
of the f2 pawn so Queen h4 and now rook
to f1 and now Alireza finds a rush of
the h6 it's a very nice idea as if you
don't want to well if you don't want to
spend too much time calculating you play
something like Knights to d1 which is
definitely a possibility but you could
also just start running away with the
King because there's this Queen captures
on d4 idea also the e3 pawn is being
threatened
so night study one saves the III pond
however now holidays it goes for Queen
captures on d4 as the e3 pawn is pinned
you cannot capture it so King runs to c2
and now Bishop captures on e3 hoping for
Knight characters and rook captures with
a double attack here and the very
dangerous position for white however it
is possible to play this as a white has
Bishop to b2 here which also attacks
blacks Queen and now white is just
better as he is up material as you can
see white is up a bishop pair which is
not very often so Bishop to b2 right
away instead of capturing we just said
you could capture and then after rookery
captures Bishop to b2 but Ottoman goes
Bishop to b2 right away so the Queen is
under attack but now Queen to d2 check
King Tubby one and now Bishop the back
to d4 opening up and attack towards the
bishop here so here at Queen's the g2
check and it was up until this point
that white was you know utterly and
completely winning however it is a blitz
game so you don't have like a lot of
time to calculate everything it's easier
of course to attack them to defend in
short short formats so here Queens the
g2 check was played where as Queen to g3
check would have been much better
Queen to g3 check is much better because
if King gets red and rook h1 and just
ends the game and if you go to f8 then
you have Queen captures and e6 with
check so the attack continues you
connect it with Queen captures Bishop
and so on however after Queen to g2
check you don't have so many resources
and here Ali Reza finds sanctuary on f8
so King to f8 now you don't have Queen
captures here and you don't have a all
that good of a continuation so here are
having played Bishop character son
before but now ali reza is allowed rook
character Sonny - now threatening rook
see to check King a 1 followed by ro
Quinta a 1 checkmate so Queen to g7
check King te 8 and now Queen to GA to
check with King the e7 and now the
shabak the b2 at least after this check
and here you do not have Queen a to as
the the Bishop is blocking the Queensway
and well now you just don't don't have a
way of winning this however there is one
way so maybe if you
you can even pause the video here and
try to find the the winning move for
black here once again while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the only move that wins the
game and for those of you who just one
injured show its rook e1 and here you're
threatening to win the rook or if
something else happens just win capture
0 is again completely winning or if rook
captures rook then you get another Queen
into the game which is again completely
winning however ali reza misses rook to
e1 he goes for Queen to d3 with check
and now white has white has asked where
King to a1 and now how do you continue
this well I shall identify the rook
character son b2 and he opens up an
attack against White's rook on f1 so
white goes for the counter-attack Queen
g5 check King to e6 and now there is
nothing better so King characters and
BTO we have Queen captures on f1 and now
Quinta III check finally nicely
connecting this and we'll pick up the F
do pawn soaking the seven and Knight
captures an f2 and after all of this
madness still it's it's a blitz game and
don't forget that we are already at move
50 and aravind is up a knight however
after capturing the c4 pawn ali reza is
up four pawns which is not easy Knight
is an extremely tricky beast in a blitz
game however four points are four points
so it's this can still go either way
so nice - d3 you want to get that night
as close to the opponent's king as
possible however it's not easy through
those pawns all of these squares are
off-limits to the night so it's not not
very easy so here our queen to be 5 with
check you want to start gobbling up even
more pawns king c2 and now Queen
captures on 85 so now Alireza is up five
pawns but white still has a knight queen
g5 and now Quinta a2 with check King to
c3 and the Queen back the e6 now
defending everything and hopefully you
can start pushing some of those past
pawns
we have Queen the g8 trying to get over
or over there and now Queen f6 check
with King to c2 and now Queen back the
e6 so now Queen does go to be a
why black allowed it and now Queen the
c4 with check came to d2 and now Queen
a2 with check with King III and now
Queen back the e6 with check however
white doesn't repeat white ghost f2 and
he says no more checks for you well
there is Queen a to check but now King
g3 and now there are no more checks so
Queen back to b3 now attacking the
knight here however white finds an
excellent idea Queen Catherine b7 with
check King to e6 and now Queen to c8
with check we have King to f6 and now
white decides to bring the Queen back to
the defense of the night however there
was an extremely strong Queen captures
on a6 you give up the night and then
well this past pawn is already very very
advanced so it's it would be a very
interesting you know you don't even give
up the knight story the Queen defends
the night that's that's a very that's
that's a winning move basically just
defend the night and this is this will
be winning however it's easy to miss
when you're low on time that this also
defends the night while clearing the way
for your pawn so here a queen to h8
check King back to e6 and now Quinta I
ate with Czech king f6 and now Quinta
III back defending the knight and the
pawn so it basically is the same thing
only it would be much better if the
Queen was here guarding both of them as
then you would also have protection for
pushing b7 here you don't so c5 by ali
reza and now whitey decides to give up a
pawn to get the Queen away from here so
b7 and Queen captures on b7 we have
Quinta h6 with check King g7 and now
comes Knight to f4 so the knight is
making progress in getting closer to the
black King but Queen to b3 with check
with King gauge for and Queen to c4
now we have Queen to g5 check and the
King to d7 and now white does grab some
of the phone so Queen captures on f5
check King to c7 and Queen to f6 now
defending everything and making it a bit
difficult for for black to move however
there is the past a pond so a5 and
comes Queen to e7 with check king c6 and
Queen to d8 with check now hoping that
the King goes back to the seven French
talking back to b7 and now Queen d7
check King Tubby six and now the d6 pawn
hang so Queen captures on d6
all with tempo and now King to b5 we
have Queen to be eight with check King
to a four and now Queen - I ate with
check the reason why there are so many
checks is because it's a it's a blitz
game and both of them are extremely low
on time and you wanna you want to always
make it your opponent's move so here of
course lose this time while you are very
safe so King a 3 and now Quinta III with
check King before and now comes King to
g5 so unpinning the knight can now
finally move but a for how it is that
continues pushing his passport now
Knight the d3 check and now the night is
finally involved in the attack against
the black ink so King a5 and now Knight
captures and c5 just going for that
capture capturing with the Queen isn't
all that impressive you could go for it
but after characters captures and a3
although you will be able to stop at the
pawn with the night it's in a voice game
you don't want to over calculate this
and also White is still hoping to maybe
even checkmate the black ink so Knight
captures on c5 and now King b5 attacking
the knight we have Knight back to d3 and
Queen to d5 check we have King to h4 and
now f6 our laser starts pushing this
point as well also takes away the e5
square from the white knight so Knights
the f4 attacking the Queen and Queen g5
check King to h3 and now Queen f5 check
came to g3 and Queen to e5 now finally
Ali Reza offers a queen trade and if the
the Queen's are traded off it's again
hard to say if you will be if you will
be in time to stop this pawn you will as
you can go nice that you want to see -
and you will be guarding the a - pawn
and then the king will also be able to
help out however after this Queen to e5
move with Queen to d3 check and King
Tubby for now we have Queen to d2 with
check Quinta c3
blocking again alvarez offers the trade
but now tonight the d3 check and here
after king to see for it was in this
position that ottomans time ran out so
really really a wild game which you know
in the end it ends by flagging but you
know all great games do and it was just
really really incredible and now i want
to it could have been it could have gone
either way but it's i I guess it was
just a matter of who will maybe pre move
faster will denied we move faster will
the point pre move faster and it's of
course a very stressful environment but
yeah this was a really really an
exciting moment after this h3 idea and
this night check so here like we
mentioned you cannot go here because of
this check but yeah even even such
strong grandmasters can miss this here
for example are I mean missed it because
he played it he allowed Queen a night to
D to check just winning the Queen and
ali reza also missed it as well
he just didn't expect maybe for Aravind
to miss it but it's still so pretty
incredible but it's not all that all
that different for example from Park
James of course not in terms of skill or
anything but there was this video that
everyone was sharing were firstly had
this fork that could win the Queen and
everyone was like laughing and
everything but here you can see it can
happen to a 2750 player like like oh it
is a fuchsia and also to a player like
like our events all you know mistakes
are there for everyone to be made sure
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
it was really really a wild one and I
don't know I do think we are going to
award Ali Reza with the morphe head for
this game whoops not Aravind holidays I
was the one sacrificing like a madman
here so there you go a Larissa you win
the morphe head congratulations man and
yeah I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Allen Asbury Marcus when
aaron anubrata bond bond FG and some
more and
Mayor Daniel album for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the park
champs checking up in your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world such as this wonderful
game here so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day